some people when they when they're going
through some let's say mental health
issues they feel like what I need to do
I need to go to Brazil and take iasa I
need to do something extreme I need to
go live in the woods for 7even days
alone is it replacing something that's
let me rephrase that is it replacing
something intense with something else
that's intense or not maybe it's okay
you could you could do that in fact
that's better go live in a cave for 30
days you know I think there are many
paths to the top of the mountain um you
know it could be that for some
individuals being in something like a
cave for 30 days might actually be
helpful that you have kind of CEO exec
types who literally do go into a kind of
a cave for a week typically and then
talk about how when they come out after
that kind of sensory deprivation they
experience incredible Euphoria by very
simple things